الى
التطور المتقدم لروسيا
وضمان الامن
منطق الوثيقه
تعكس التطورات والوقائع الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
التسارعات التي شاهدناها مع
اطلاقها لعمليه العسكريه الخاصه اول شيء
التوتر في الاوضاع العالميه
وظهور المخاطر المهدده لدولاتنا المبرره
الرئيسي
هو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والسياسه الغربيه بشكل عام هادفه الى
اضعاف روسيا
وخوض الحرب الهجينه ضد روسيا وهنا
كذلك
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
سياسه العولمه
الاقتصاديه
والاقتصاد العالمي
يواجه
التغيرات الجسيمه
وظهور مراكز اقتصاديه جديده
والتقدم نحو العالم المتعدده الاقسام
ووضعنا
مبدا
النظام العالمي العادل والمتزن
وقدم المساواه للدول
وحق الدول
النمط الوطني لتطورها
وتحديد الاهداف
بنفسها
وشددنا على ضروره الضمان القانونيه
في العلاقات الدوليه
والقانون الدولي لابد ان ياخذ بان
الاعتبار وخائع العالم المتغير
وكما يجب الالتزام بمبدا الامن غير قبل
لتجزئه
والعمل في الامم المتحده يعتمد على فعاليه
هذه العمل هذه المنظمه
ومراعات مبادئ ميثاقها
التي يحاول الغرب ان يخربها
وكذلك
المبادئ لاستخدام القوه في حاله الدفاع عن
الذات
العقيده
تنص ايضا على اتخاذ الاجراءات
بالمثل
وغير بالمثل
لاستباقيه الهجوم على روسيا او ردع الهجوم
المهدد لروسيا ونحن
نحافظ على حقنا
للتطور العادل
وكذلك
نحافظ على القيم
الاخلاقيه التقليديه الروسيه
والحفاظ على
الاتجاه المناسب لجميع الطوائف والاديان
في روسيا
وبين الاولويات الروسيه ضمان حقوق مواطنين
مكافحه كراهيه الروس
وتعزيز وضع اللغه الروسيه والدفاع عن
ثقافاتنا
وعدم تاسيس الرياضه
واشكال جديده للتعاون الرياضي
ونركز ايضا على التكامل ليوثي اعتمادا على
الدوله الاتحاديه روسيا
والاعتماد ايضا على منظمه
الامن الجماعي
مورد رئيسي
نرى اتجاه
نحو
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع دول الكبرى مثل
الصين والهند والدول الاسلاميه
ودول القاره الافريقيه وامريكا اللاتينيه
ومحيط كاريبيا
وايضا نركز على ضروره التسويه السلميه
لجميع القضايا والمشكلات الظاهره في هذه
المناطق
وجميع المحاولات
خرق السياده
سنرد عليها
بشده
ونحن ننطلق من ان العالم
الانجلوسوني
بدايه تنوين نوايا سيئه بنسبه
لروسيا والدول المتقدمه
وعليها ان
تمتنع عنها سياساتها المعاديه لروسيا
والعالم الحره الديمقراطيه
عمل غير سهل
وفي ظروف هذه الجديده
سنساهم كل مساهماتنا
مع
بتنسيق
وسنقدم نتائج هذا العمل حسب القرار الموكع
من قبلكم
والخطوات في الاتجاهات اشكركم على
العقيده المقدمه اعتقد تخدم
اعمالنا اللاحقه في المجال الدولي ومن
ناحيه العمليه
ارجو جميع الزملاء
المتعلقين
بالسياسه الخارجيه يركز